at the height of my career I had a dream
that I was holding a fence should tiny
delicate bird and it was my pet and I
put it back into its cage auditioning
like crazy I had been pounding the
pavement and there was the breaking
point where I'm tired I'm tired I don't
know if I'm gonna do this anymore no
one's seeing me
oh he's do this or he's too bad or he's
too flamboyant or he's black of that you
know I heard from oil so many times I
wasn't sort of either thing that society
said that I should be and so I always
felt a little out of place I thought oh
there's no place for someone like me I'm
too weird I'm probably too gay I just
could not get a show mate I couldn't get
a show made and I didn't want to write
it I didn't think it was that
fascinating didn't think was that
entertaining I was just thinking it's
just I can't how much longer can I do
this without having a breakthrough
literally the next day I get a telephone
call and my agent sends me this script
and the character breakdown for the
character of Taylor Mason said
non-binary hello I'm Taylor my pronouns
are they there's and then okay
you